hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to let's play this beep is
goofy that got me
okay SCP containment breach uh someone
informed me that I contained the old man
radical Larry in error air for air for
could not complete the game so what I'm
gonna do is I'm going to I updated 26.0
zero point six point three which has a
few new additions that I wanted to get
into anyway so I'm just going to start a
new game and I'm gonna hunt down scp-096
because he's in the game now and if you
don't know who that is go read up on the
SCP wiki who that is it's a great SCP
damn terrifying but I'm gonna hunt him
down make him my [ __ ] and whatnot mmm
also there was something about 173 now
has different poses like painting like
one of your french girls
ah so let's just get into it
oh the old familiar ways okay yeah
yeah I know oh hello
hi what are you doing down here
everybody not moving okay you just
you stay there buddy I'm glad to have
you as a friend all right
so let's carry on I really do appreciate
the updated and what though won't it oh
that one was a dud okay
I really do appreciate the updated
animations and stuff it does feel like
the game is a lot more fluid so I mean
it just like feels every single update
there's a little bit more
professionalism to the game and I feel
like it's a game that your verbs a lot
more than it it has hello hi he's down
there uh-uh
talk about to say I didn't hear him
zipping around so I wasn't sure if he
was get off there I'm not a dud link oh
ma I'm on a hunt miss thumb bit down and
I'm gonna get him o is the other duck
here hey ducky hi Oh where'd you go ah
oh hey hey one-seventh right by
appalling [ __ ]
Jesus go God what are you doing there
jeez holy baloney how did you get there
no what's this app balls not what I need
ah get away get away get away
how how did huh I don't even I don't
even know how you got there he did it
again
he did it again how how hi they also
include the loading times I close this
door how did he how the fudging [ __ ]
did he get to me wait why is there why
can't I move in here is he like wait
wait a minute I can't I can't seem to
move hang on
I'm alright something's in there okay
that must be a bug slight problem attic
oh ah which doorway
ah holy balls how do you do that
what does that does new sound holy
schnikeys man jeez jeez Louise
screw that entirely I've got another way
holy baloney died in a fire you think
Jesus holy balls even though you know
all right
that is okay this is officially the
condemned section no one's allowed to go
in there cuz holy mackerel on a cracker
I don't even know I don't even know they
already have that I don't need that
again I mean wow why why God
Seve oh come on wait I don't see him in
there
oh he's in there okay here we go oh yeah
yeah in the middle the room there buddy
ah oh
like whoa where am I what camera I'm not
movin I'm not mavin ha are you good out
of me you gotta be kidding me the door
closed early I I do appreciate that they
they vastly oh no oh no oh no oh no oh
oh no oh no no no no no aah they did
increase the loading time for when you
die it's much faster but I had to get
out and get back in but I I do
appreciate that the loading time was
faster when you died because that was a
bit a bit tedious to have to go through
this every time and now that Billy is
exceptionally more aggressive I don't
know ha he just I don't I don't even
it's just like you know it's like you
know I don't even know what it's like
and it's just you know yeah what the hi
what it seems to be some weirdness going
on
where are you okay you're right there
okay data where yeah where you are
honey hell bloody hell I don't know
what's going on but it seems like
there's either some more bugs or things
are just going weird okay come on get
out of that doorway man I need to go
around you on yeah that doorway I'll get
out of the doorway you dick there we go
that's good enough I can work with this
there you are and how the how the bloody
hell the door like closes instantly ow
all right I can't I don't know there
seems to be a bug with the doors
okay but I'm not going that way either
I'm like I'm screwed I'm screwed no
matter which way what the what what what
hi ah ah ah I got stuck in the door
there's a problem with the doors holy
baloney okay I don't know I don't know
what's going on guys I'm just gonna
start a new game because I can't I can't
take this anymore either my game was
bugged that particular seed was bugged
which is possible considering I played a
lot of seeds you know could Kip bug
Billy was super aggressive and invisible
at times which kind of hurt be trying to
keep an eye on him and the doors kept
slamming shut in my face that it kept me
from going through that gas room I don't
know don't know what what's up with 8:60
I haven't seen that in the game then
again I haven't seen a lot of this stuff
in the game uh ha ha ha ha ha
let's just try again let's just try it
again all right again all right going
forward no Billy no bad news no bad news
miss bears do your head is turned okay I
get it I get it I get it I get it I get
it I get it close the damn door oh oh
god oh no oh no oh no oh no oh no let me
through let me through let me through
let me through let me through oh god oh
god oh god which way do I go
Oh God no okay ah stay ah stay stay
you [ __ ] you [ __ ] you dirty dirty Oh
you hope dirty dirty dirty huh you're a
dirty dirty dirty dirty ho dirty Oh
dirty ho ah dirt where to go where to go
let's go holy balls Wow look easy
he's gonna zoom around there down there
forever damn it I don't have the card
god damn Billy I do not like going
through those rooms not happy funtime
there's exactly not happy not why is he
so damn aggressive now what did I do
oh good I'll go too good oh good oh god
oh god oh god oh good good good good
good good good good excellent most
excellent I've got stuff now okay so I
take these I go to the machine I'll go
through the arduous process of upgrading
this level by level on fine just fine
Kirby oh man I don't know what the deal
is cuz I mean this is excruciating I
mean I don't even know what what I don't
even know what I'm doing
I don't even know what I'm doing anymore
I think you know I get to the point
where I think I know this game and then
obviously I do not it's still on fine
good let's save lamb
come on come on come on come on come on
thank you thank you thank you let's get
going let's get going
still on fine save I got here
I guess the new pose is just him going
with his head turn because that's how he
was in the original pictures like this
will be fifty so that that's what it was
and the one they've used whoa whoa
oh that worried me for a second I got
pushed and I never liked getting pushed
in games I can't see what's going on
haha okay I'm just freaking out a little
bit okay yeah I got my Omni card okay
now just do the gas mask and navigator
and I'll be good Who am I am very fine
hold your tits there buddy ah give me
give me give me a gift got those who
alright huh all right good
I got these I got my gas masks feels
like it's easier to breathe than
normally all right
saved save not [ __ ] moving forward get
away you douche I never need to go that
way again I'm officially out of the
woods from the direction let's go this
way okay
my mission is still defined oh yeah this
SCP is actually here now it's um it
actually exists so I got it like you
know the little thing that I saw in that
one episode somewhere yeah it's um yeah
it's around now I probably just
unleashed him on the unsuspecting me
I don't know anything anymore I don't
know anything anymore
closing that haha whoa I guess that's
all the time I have for it is Oh No yeah
actually I'm out of time this is a good
place to stop as any in my opinion so
thank you all so much for watching hope
you're enjoying the newness cuz holy
crap he is everywhere so thank you so
much for watching and as always I will
see you in the next video bye bye